はじめしゃちょー t シャツが出来ました
ん
どうですか
まあまあ色々突っ込みたいところがあると思います
ん
こんなんですよ
これですよこれうーんイヤーの猫の旅 t シャツを作らせていただいたんですけど
やっぱね
難しいには t シャツデザインっていろいろ考えたんでかっこいいんだとか候補社員
なを考えたんですけど
結論的にこんな感じなっちゃいました
そんなにかこう良くないでしょ友達にも言われたんですよで遠くから見たら普通はそう
いうオシャレな t シャツに見えるなんてほらこういう難から写真撮影とかありそう
でしょ
意外といいでしょというわけだよ始めさぞ t シャツ
こんな感じでございます女の方が着るとこんな感じになります
いや似合ってるよ吉広
銀髪とではたぐいまれに見るや破壊力だと思っ
ちなみに僕は今ウェブサイト身長185センチの細身でちょっとたいとくらいです津波
に
よしかも
モデルさんだから知らん
ないけど吉熊 m サイズでこんな感じですちなみにこの t シャツですね今日8月
4日19時から発売開始です動画は説明欄にアマゾンのサイトを載せておくね
どこの説明はクリックしたサイトに飛べます
s サイズ m サイズ l サイズ準備させていただきました
s サイズが60倍で m サイズが125
前 l サイズ15枚準備してあります多分ねえ目さえたいていの人はね目サイズ買え
ばいいと思うんだよ
デナーキーなる値段なんだけど一応1万円39800円で売らせていただきます
嘘ですそうですよまあは多少ね限界までコストを抑えることによってね1980年
変えますそんなにおかしいと思う
6水よそういう感じで作ったもんインパクトというサ
ウソでしょこんなの
何かもしれないということなんですよこの t シャツは音も手に入ることはないんで
ね
ぜひ
皆さんよかったら来てみてくださいあなたしか買えないのと一応300万して準備して
いないのでなるべくお早めに購入しちゃってください
パッと見オサレなんだよな
います
eh
お母さんが帰ってきたん
お母さん合体できのさ
お空追加も帰ってきました
まあまあ
いえいっぽいけど